As it turns out, when you compute the accuracy you can actually see that,
that the simpler decision boundary gives you a better result.
You have a 91.2% accuracy with the min_sample_split set to 50.
And then when you allow it to go all the way down to two,
you only get 90.8% accuracy.
So, you can see that it does make a difference,
not just in terms of how the decision boundary looks, but
actually in terms of the performance of your classifier.
And, this might not look like a huge difference.
But, that's something that we got for free just by tuning a parameter.
And, if you recall, there were a lot of parameters that we had to play around with
in decision trees.
So, I would encourage you right now or at some point in the future to sort of
go in and play with, around with a lot of those.
Get some intuition for what they're controlling and
how they actually change the shape of the decision boundary.
Because in the future, those are going to be the parameters that you're going to
be tuning to get the best performance out of your algorithm